let's have a look inside the question
answering pipeline
the question answering pipeline can
extract answers to questions from a
given context or passage of text like
this part of the transformers reaper
read me
it also works for very long contexts
even if the answer is at the very end
like in this example
in this video we'll see why
the question answering pipeline follows
the same steps as the other pipelines
the question and context are tokenized
as a sentence pair fed to the model when
some post-processing is applied
so tokenization and model steps should
be familiar
we use the other class suitable for
question answering instead of sequence
classification
but one key difference with text
is that our model outputs two tone
source named start logics and and logics
why is that well this is the way the
model finds the answer to the question
first let's have a look at the model
inputs it's numbers associated with the
tokenization of the question followed by
the context
with the usual cls and sub special
tokens
the answer is a part of the second
so we ask the model to predict which
token starts the answer and which ends
the answer
for two logit outputs the theoretical
labels are the pink and purple vectors
to convert those logits into
probabilities we'll need to apply a
softmax like in the text classification
pipeline
we just mask the tokens that are not
part of the context before doing that
leaving the initial cls token unmasked
as we use it to predict an impossible
answer
this is what it looks like in terms of
code
we use a large negative number for the
masking
since its exponential will then be zero
now the probability for each start and
end position corresponding to a possible
answer
will give a score that is a product of
the start probabilities and n
probabilities at this position
of course a start index greater than an
n index corresponds to an impossible
answer
here is the code to find the best score
for a possible answer
once we have the start and end position
for the tokens we use the offset
mappings provided by our tokenizer to
find the span of characters in the
initial context and we get our
answer when the context is long it might
get truncated by the tokenizer
this might result in part of the answer
or worse the whole answer being
truncated
so we don't discard the truncated tokens
but build new features with them each of
those features contains a question
then a chunk of text in the context
if we take these shown chunks of text we
might end up with a sensor being split
between two features
so instead we take overlapping chunks of
text to make sure at least one of the
chunks will fully contain the answer to
the question
the tokenizer does all of this for us
automatically with the return
overflowing tokens option
the stride argument controls the number
of overlapping tokens
here is how a very long context gets
truncated into two features with some
overlap
by applying the same post-processing we
saw before for each feature we get the
answers with the score for each of them
and we take the answer with the best
score as a final solution